we met two times Botha Carlos the first
time was when I had graduated in 2014
and Jenny was still a junior at that
time we were both part of an
organization on campus called the
InterVarsity Christian Fellowship and
every year during carnival they have an
Alumni Reunion as well so I had come
back and I had met Jenny and then we
lost contact after that and then fast
forward two more years later a year
after I graduated we both came back for
Carnival that year and we met again at
the same alumni the fellowship alumni
reunion events during carnival Sam
really remembered me to me my first time
but I must have just still been Sammy
mindsight because I didn't remember
meeting I remembered you the second time
because I think I just like you yeah at
that point for the second meeting I was
in Atlanta she was still in Pittsburgh
kept talking and kept talking we kind of
started out long like long-distance
messaging I had written this whole
speech and I had written everything that
I liked about her and so for the very
first time I said hey listen let's me go
chat so we set up a time to video chat
we got on and I just like dumped on her
I was like you know I really like
thinking about you all this time and and
and then I kind of asked her out from
there and what did you say I said okay I
think that like it's really more that we
both still come to CMU together often
yeah like often times when we talk about
oh let's have a day it will think about
you know one of us will suggest let's go
go to gates or let's go to see him you
walk around very let's go watch the
sunset behind one of the buildings or in
front of hamish leg we got our
engagement photos taking on campus so I
personally I really like it that I feel
like even though we're both out of
school that Sam you still like a big
part of your life and that we're still
here we don't feel so far we mean it's
fun to be in the same place but be a
different person we met a carnival and
we fell in love and so can you
[Music]
you